we have a clip from the new season this
is your thing this is exciting because I
don't think anyone's seen much from the
new season this is exciting I myself
have seen nothing nothing I understand
I'm that's the only reason you came here
I understand gotta go on Conan I don't
want to go on that they got your clip
I gotta see it III understand in this
clip i play remarkably handsome guy
tries to save i'm sent in to clean up
the mess that Matthew Modine did last
year where I'm always cleaning up his
mess and you're a doctor I'm a many
degree doctor I have many degrees I'm an
experts and everything and yet I myself
know nothing so yeah it's funny you were
telling me that you your character has
to know all this incredibly complex
stuff right but about the crazy world of
stranger things in the different
dimensions but you yourself I don't
laughter you don't know what you're
talking but I feel as an actor I should
make the effort do a little research so
they honest see what they said okay so
you're just gonna stand here and you
look out the window and then we'll put
in all the stuff later in computer you
know CGI we'll put it in and I said well
okay but just tell me what what exactly
what am I looking and what what is
happening they said well it's it you
know in the upside down it's it's it's
like a vortex and it's a it's a parallel
universe but the molecular that's a you
know I'll just I'll just say any other
day just hang an orange on a string and
I look at I said I'll see it exactly
I'll see it when I'm on Conan that's
yeah exactly do we need no anything for
this scene I don't know what it is I've
never seen the show here it is let's
take a look
[Applause]
so I went outside and it was worse I was
worse there was a storm so how did you
feel when you saw this door I felt
frozen heart racing
frozen frozen cold total I'm closing to
the touch how do you feel when you're
standing and you can't breathe or talk
or do anything
I felt I felt this evil like like it was
looking at me well what do you think the
evil wanted
that's scary you have no idea because
when I'm there I'm just talking and then
the kid does all the acting and I just
ask him everything
yeah but I then here they didn't have
you sick in the light yeah I heard no
not believe me I would have not have
gotten involved yeah talking to a kid
that was like the Brady Bunch
you